party people yeah what if I did a whole
Braveheart themed went there it is
right then thank you for minutes yeah I
didn't even write on this trailer I was
just writing our tag team won't there
disparity freedom there it is hey guys
welcome to honest trailer commentaries a
show talking about a show that's talking
about another show I'm Joe Dan Danielle
hey we're talking a Braveheart today so
hopefully you watch the honest trailer
and you came back and watch this or
you're crazy and you watched this first
and then you watch the honest trailer
like a lunatic Braveheart thoughts
Spencer's not here because he's
recovering from the worst episode ever
worst episode of Game of Thrones he's at
home just stewing yeah he worked on a
Sunday night that's why he's not here if
you want to know yeah that is yeah that
is honest that is honestly a Braveheart
a classic yes yeah it's fun it's fun to
do this one I like these for summer ones
they're fun yeah
I feel renewed in a way that we haven't
to go back and and not only to do these
but we're not always chasing release
dates which is great and fun and we like
it but sometimes it's nice to we get
more time to breathe yeah release take
Jason it would does hurt sometimes
especially in the in the first quarter
of the year January through March
there's just yeah so hard like you know
glass fine it's yeah it's it's hard
sometimes you just be like okay what are
we gonna do but this has given us an
opportunity to just do a bunch of random
stuff that we wouldn't do otherwise and
Braveheart is one of those it's so good
and also so ridiculous yeah yeah yeah I
first saw this oh my parents wanted me
to watch this movie and I was like no
mom and dad like they they had rented it
and they're gonna come watch a movie
with us and it was like don't suck and
I went back to tavern chat on AOL to to
roleplay yeah and I am 90% sure that I
saw this in school I saw Pulp Fiction in
school for the boys disarm a robber with
your wits and and dialogue Bible verses
in today's class on how to be a bad eh
ever frolic er yeah look we my health
teacher had to do a course on fire
safety and we watched towering inferno
okay well that just makes sense baby
yeah better backyards all the lessons
all the lessons you need yeah this
movie's big silly and ridiculous and I
as much as I want to go in and start
making fun of it any time I watch it by
like the halfway point I'm just like you
fight on the field of sterling dammit
you can fight you in I just get into it
I can't help it
it is a bygone era though when some
Australian American dude could just be
like I'm gonna tell the story of
Scottish independence and everyone's
just like cool yeah man yeah now we just
grabbed Jared Harris or any random
person from the BBC yeah yeah yeah it's
it's big and ambitious and dumb it's it
really is a dumb movie but dumb in a
good way a dumb Best Picture winner it
is a dumb PES picture winner it cleaned
up it launched a very bloody filmography
for not great dude it's the beginning of
his bloody era yeah he just directed man
without a face
the man was signed of faces Mel Gibson's
directorial debut yeah for those that
don't know he cast himself as a man he
took people's faces off yeah with an axe
yeah
West's director winner yeah Best Picture
winner s score I believe so they want a
handful yeah every way yeah won a couple
won a couple let me ask you this what is
the best thing
yelled in Scottish in this movie all of
it I don't know don't make me pick
between my babies they're just all
Scottish yelling is good in this movie
yep
yeah Gerard Butler gets so much credit
for this advancement of Scottish yelling
fairly because he is he's good actually
Scottish but I do feel like this
Australian American really did a lot
around the world for Gerard Butler
Scottish yelling yeah yelling to inspire
all the Scottish soldiers played by
actual Irish soldiers yes played by
Scottish people Scottish or Irish and
that's crazy
you guys complain all the time that we
mix up our uk's and our brexit sandauer
Ireland's and our spices ooh so you all
right to do so but we have an excuse and
it's because there's Americans and this
is one this is how we learned that's all
wrong yeah it's all wrong none of its
right
Scottish people that have dwelt in
Scotland have worn kilts since the
caveman days and that's what I know
that's why I know about Scotland all
Scotland always had kilts and bagpipes
always always at all times and axes
never not having those things yeah yeah
only forever and at some point they were
fantasy dwarves yes yeah because all
fantasy dwarves also Scottish yeah for
some reason okay I'm gonna know when
that happened because all fantasy
dwarves are Scottish Gimli Scottish like
every other fit that's the only British
another all Scottish I don't know it's
weird we should watch this trailer
mm-hmm although we could just experiment
with how long the audience will watch
before we start watching the trailer
let's do it I don't know watch the
trailer I'm bad at this honest about
summer blockbusters past and present
this is honest trailers blockbusters
summer
Oh big great graphic great grand great
graphic four years ago congratulations
all lost here Peter Parker got mad then
he lost his wife and got lethal now
he'll lose his wife and get brave in the
thought that guy could grieve hard sorry
I think that was the first decision we
made about this trailer yes
can we put bagpipes on the band's yeah
yeah we're showing as much respect for
Scottish culture as Mel Gibson did yeah
I think that's fair I think that's
completely fair I think that's that's
not untrue yeah he's also I lost a lot
of wives on both sides of the fiction
line yeah yeah mm-hmm yeah it's weird
how you see actors there's now like are
they seeking the roles out do the role
suits they magnetized towards each other
yeah bizarre let's go
the men are loud the women are silent
and everyone's hair is Brody with their
claws I had so much more about
disgusting everyone is in this movie the
children are nasty they're covered in
filth and throwing rocks at each other
no one there's the Internet comfort like
the big controversy about how some
people don't wash their legs I saw that
on Twitter did you see this on Twitter
my heard secondhand stuff it was weirdly
racially coded I know a lot of people of
all of all races who don't wash their
legs but no one in this movie is a leg
washer at one point they go they go
through like Oh wake and I'm like the
waters right there you could just scrub
it up all that down and they still come
out of the water disgusting yeah I don't
yeah cuz that with that water they're
all like in in deep Loch Ness just like
Washington dinosaur mud but the women
are all clean oh yeah you know what you
don't want dirty women in a movie
Danielle were you crazy got a VI candy
scrubbed clean
I mean honestly they probably everyone
on the planet Earth at this time was
probably dirtier than that really
disgusting it's like Hollywood dirty
yeah
that's my favorite thing about period
movies at all time is that anytime
someone kisses I'm like man their
breasts bad you guys taste bad yeah I
just watched Barry Lyndon for the first
time not too long ago and I was thinking
of that just how bad even even in those
nice clothes everyone must have just
smelled awful well what I love too is
like are there no there's somehow no
towns in Scotland it's all just hovels
and fields like there were there were
now there were towns like there were the
lowlands in Scotland that were like just
looked like well they went to any but
yeah they did that's where all the fancy
people with the clean looking ones Bruce
looked very clean and nicely had a
nicely quaffed goatee that's putting
brush on his own on his own barn no yeah
no that's not a self thrush sure the
coachella brains really bugged me I
didn't give myself a second cuz it's so
gross understand also a good use of the
word grody let's go Jake probably the
most historically accurate right let's
take ya history snootiest conquerors
Scottish rebels have Wallace will get
some payback but there's no defense
Scotsman he'll never be husband went to
a frenzy he'll stare you into his bed
it's just I say he's down I mean these
were the guns of the time yeah this dude
loves rocks better sticks rocks maybe
maybe he was throwing sticks well me
maybe there was that Batman Begins scene
that got cut where he's got like a rock
and a stick and he tries to throw a
stick and they're like no and then
Brendan Gleeson is like rocks it has
[Laughter]
all-important cutscene yeah from
Braveheart videos now on
there's and there is so much staring in
this movie and I know we specifically
call out his staring at women but there
are so many scenes where it'll be so
long of two people just looking at each
other
Amell really he was trying to give
everyone their close-up baby blues yeah
I gotta use him you gotta using he does
pain and he does he does staring like a
really really well great pain face great
pain face yeah yeah and soul also
apparently yeah let's go for a tale all
about taking back liberty that takes
every liberty with the true story
because if it were accurate
there'd be no kills bagpipes or face
paint no wife princess or plot centric
Audrey message for the youth of today
that is called cooking that is action
that is the actual meaning of it no no I
think in that scene at the wedding they
were talking about representation in
media and then the English guys came in
and yes because they were talking about
yeah that is that is actual cuckoldry
this this we talked about this in the
room this movie is predicated entirely
on the textbook definition of cuckoldry
which i like they used real cuckoldry in
an instance where it didn't exist
because there was no action yeah not a
thing yeah oh it's de parent according
to law and the professor oh it's it's
highly debatable God and very possibly
not true I'm sure it happened like
because life and real is awful like I'm
sure that the rich dude Lord in town
would roll in and just be like haha but
like as a written Longshanks right the
law and then send it out to the Lords of
the land wants to sleep with
so therefore yeah well and also they you
know Tony Stark does make a joke about
that when in age of Ultron when he tries
to lift the hammer and he says if I
become king the first thing I will do is
reenact prima noctus if y'all didn't
know what that meant when he said it
that's what he meant it's a great heart
word yeah cuz Iron Man left Braveheart
let's go and Wallace's big speech before
a battle was actually behold I have
brought you into a ring now Carolyn
dance as well as you can huh but you're
not here to loss so this idea actually
didn't realize this when we started
working in the honest trailer I knew
that most of the historical stuff was
was kind of BS yeah and I've read a few
kind of conflicting things that were
like they saw a statue William Wallace
they're like who's that it was explained
to them then they wrote a story and then
they researched it but what I didn't
know is that they're there most of their
resource and reference was just this
like epic poem written about William
Wallace
so it's BS like just based on BS which I
so it almost it's almost more of like a
King Arthur legend where it's like I
don't know we've got this thing about
how he like pulled a demon out of a rock
and that's what we got but that's the
most historical fact as we got so you're
saying we should forget what we think we
know yes I I wonder if there is a
deleted scene where he tried to do this
word-for-word and then they're like it's
not working not going no I'm just
thinking of a Soul Train line just a
bunch of them in Asarco each one of them
gets to dance I get a wedding dance as
well as you can get alright huh but
you're not here to learn you're here for
all the hot sweaty action
whether it's man on man man on horse or
arrow in but Brave Hearts got more
violence than you can shake a field full
of dicks - do you like torture you do
well thank you for being honest weirdo
down strap yourself in this bill is
adding to his bitterly long resume of
pays they ruined that movie they did big
director's cut in an endless torture
finale that makes it clear what drew him
to the story Rock hey hey you know what
they say follow your passion that's the
kind of Hollywood epic they don't really
make anymore where the armies are real
The Scotsman are Australian and you
forgive all of its many flaws because it
gets you pumped every single time
[Music]
[Applause]
back bodydrop pause we talked about it
is sort of it's one of the last of the
because it was huge and epic but it was
at a time when if you needed four
thousand people on a battlefield you
would just go hire four thousand people
that each other a battlefield as opposed
to hiring you know five hundred people
and and doing the rather that's what I
love and so I love about even the arts
of Arabia and Spartacus and all of these
movies where you look at a scene of
5,000 people and you realize that they
just went got 5,000 people yeah that's
visual effects are great but mm-hmm I
have yet to see a visual effects battle
scene that looks as brutally authentic
as that because it's it is it reminds me
of the crowd if you're playing a video
game the crowded the sports game or you
know the people in the back of MORTAL
KOMBAT so you can see the first row of
people I mean it just gets blurrier and
blurrier yeah you know that's why you
know even if you look at Lord of the
Rings like I love so much what they did
with the visuals and the armies and the
first time you see the first alliance
between ups and men like it looks
incredible but I'll take the shots of
like a hundred and fifty lady New
Zealanders dressed up as Riders of Rohan
like you know storming down towards
Aragorn and company like those shots are
just awesome
yeah and banking that it's so stylized
to that even those big CG shots
everything is scaled up to such a degree
then that it makes sense because
everything is just crazy
whereas I found movies like this where
they do an old you know historical drama
and they use CG for most of the crowd it
just doesn't it feels fake yeah it does
it does it does yeah fun fact I think
this movie was investigated by
an animal rights organization because
they thought the horses are actually
getting hurt
mmm and that they weren't paid courses
there are very clearly moments where
those horses are fake yeah it's not when
he rides out of the building forward
those old plastic breyer horses yeah
yeah no the yeah the battle scenes are
awesome one of the other historical
things people to try to dunk on it for
is sterling was supposed to be about a
small bridge there's no bridge but it's
like did you really want to watch 20
minutes of like two guys crossing a
bridge at a time and then getting as
they crossed like that sucks yeah it's
not a fun movie none of its real
the only historical movies very few of
them or any yeah cuz real life is super
boring the way that it happens it is
it's better when it's flattened and
condensed and then heightened yeah
that's why I like football movies over
football games oh my god yes because you
just get all the big like Hollywood
stylized impacts and no like sitting for
20 minutes while ESPN films coaches hang
out yeah exactly one of the fun things I
always like to do with these battle with
battle scenes like this is to check the
background because everyone does not
always realize they are on camera yeah
they're just going like where's crafty
yeah I'm very hungry man yeah Braveheart
let's go story funny names killed Burger
King bad guy there's something about
modern have fun storming the castle
Adam it had me here tormund medium spain
when the drugs
go ahead so I don't know what movie he
thought he was in he's in a different
movie than everybody totally different
movie I mean I dig it this is I said
Kevin note pause it was just like we
just put some Robert the Bruce clips
together with dubstep genius yeah it's
not a bad it's not bad it's just that
everyone else is in a different movie
than he's in yeah I love what he does
but heaven this is not in miracle max
are in a different film talking to this
weird
Skeletor looking leper god it's just
it's always been the weird thing is like
there and like willow is Braveheart it's
very it's weird
very bizarre forgotten how I've always
sheltered that and that part of the
v-series did let's go I used to be an
adventurer like you until I took an
arrow to the chair nose-to-nose jostled
and yeah and another axe to the gut and
Game of Thrones
this contest
[Music]
white Klansmen suppose Sherman
sometimes we have a debate no we
couldn't pass this with a see yeah
literally the only debate I brought up
was because we hadn't really done
anything to ping mell yet yeah was like
maybe that should have been his starring
just to be like we got him a little it's
such a good it's so good for the title I
mean when are we ever gonna get a chance
to use that title again
I don't know bordering appropriate way I
don't know if we'll ever get another
shot yeah no no it's perfect and as
usual incredible graphics pretty sure
Robert probably built that sword from
scratch I would dollars to doughnuts
Robert you jerk alright it's so good
sure Mel was almost 40 playing a guy in
his early 20s but to be fair people aged
hard back then I mean look at this guy
he's 35 that dudes a champion screamer
he's really good at it
that was like again for for a little
inside the room talk that was the first
joke I wrote when watching the movie
back and in three different drafts it
ended up in three different places in
the script because I review so that's
what happens that's one small
inheritance so yeah I was like you know
what
because yeah cuz I wrote like Mel Gibson
too old to play William Wallace and then
yeah maybe he's 30 there's a joke that
was very sad to see go which one it's in
the deleted okay yeah it's a starring
name brave hearts got more violence than
you can shake a field full of dicks at
and they'll make the villain extremely
gay
anything sadness left
nope nothing insecurities a year twice
as long as a month some men are longer
than others now go back to the part
where they ran the flaming wood into the
gate
whoa those dudes look hot you know from
the flames of the long wooden shaft paws
and that dizzily cut mm-hmm and I think
it was really just cuz 300 totally a Top
Gun yes yes but yeah well you can take
things out of context like thing you
know other things but I think we're just
going no forced yeah it's funny but it's
not super honest yeah so yeah exactly I
think we might have the route so what
happened was we had two different runs
one about historical accuracy and then
all of the all the violent stuff was a
part of that and then I think we just
and just merge those together Kevin yes
yeah Kevin brilliant job very very
brilliant
yes let's go behold I have brought you
into a ring now Carolyn dance as well as
you can
huh yeah screw that let's just Yelp
freed up and do NFL kickoff with swords
[Music]
yeah it's a big merging I do like the
musical I now and get gun battle
groundskeeper Willie is Mel
Oda Mort one wedding in a funeral and
broke buzz that's the one I love it
Bruce so much I love brendan gleeson so
much that I was very shy I get why we
had to go with tormund Spain but I was
very sad to see it broke yeah in Bros
yeah that's the 1% oh yeah oh my god is
that that is a definite one person
everyone presenter but it's super good
nice game Jay a dude playing a dude
disguised as another dude Free Willy
yeah that's the movie that's the trailer
um guru will this is a fun movie to go
back and watch I haven't seen it in a
long time actually neither yes him yeah
I think I just used to have this on like
all the time just to have dudes crashing
into each other and chopping heads
playing yes this was at my well I guess
now there's been three to the second
three there was like three hundred and
two thousand and like what six or
whatever 2007 there was gladiator 2001
mm-hmm for like people of a certain like
high school age
this was the gladiator of my like cuz I
was 13 yeah this is 12 5 12 13 when this
came out yeah so for when I was in high
school this was like gladiator was two
people that word a few years are gonna
make oh yeah I listen to the score all
the time yes I think this is the movie
that made me a score nerd no I think it
is this is like the first score CD that
I got listened it's like it's like
predator and back to the future
listen to this score and listen to
Titanic there's a lot of crime there's
one cue that I'm almost positive was
used in both yeah
very very very similar scores it's a
brilliant composer and you know
sometimes I got a hit James Horner was
incredible
the of the best composers of all time
Alan Silvestri what are the best
composers of all time but sometimes when
you have big movies next to each other
you got it yeah it'll get a pick pick
and to you know look like anybody else
they've got their their toolbox and
their bag of tricks that they like to
pull from and sometimes you you you pull
from the bag of tricks once too many
times and everyone notices but yeah
whatever
they're brilliant dudes any closing
thoughts on Braveheart you guys a little
bit oh it's out always will
I want to Manny Danielle any other
thoughts on Braveheart why does he want
to marry her when he was a baby and then
he met no women in France or Rome again
and no one else was impressed with me in
the room and everyone was like shut up
you're like when did he get old Maddie
and kiltie again let you bro you grew up
and wrong I grew up in Vatican City
I could spend like three hours in the
woods and start getting dirty I can
imagine tripping out to the highlands
Scotland with a kilt and it's like
welcome home buddy
no yeah let's get the Paris off yeah
okay these guys stinks of the mainland I
[Laughter]
got us off are we dumb I don't know
maybe I can't hear us anymore
[Music]